I know firsthand how quickly he can move
and he knows exactly what he's doing
exactly what he's doing this is the
first time louise anton has spoken
publicly about her ordeal at the hands
of rolf harris
she felt no one would believe her until
now she says the entertainer indecently
assaulted her in 2008 as they had their
photo taken at a function so i could
feel as as plain as day his hand running
down my back and it rested on the top of
my bottom and then he slid his fingers
and in between and did that several
times and I just I just couldn't believe
what was happening I could feel every
bit of what he did in true Australian
fashion I said are you right and just
glared at him and he looked at me and
said it feels good damnit with this
smirk on his face and I just I don't
know everything just started spinning
and I just couldn't believe this had
happened Rolf Harris grew up in this
Perth suburb children adored him
everyone was proud of their local hero
after moving to the UK he still made
regular trips home like here in 1966
signed a few autographs for one of the
Commonwealth policemen there his two
daughters signing autographs at the
airport before he'd even got off the
runway but over the years some saw a
side to his character kept well away
from the TV cameras Rolf went from being
the good clean family man but my
grandmother admired to being a dirty old
man a very dirty old man who was
opportunistic and thought that he could
get away with a level of humiliation
that I had not experienced Jane Marwick
is a writer and broadcaster she
interviewed Harris on
radio in 2001 and says she was also
groped by him as they posed for a photo
his hand sort of landed in the middle of
my back and his fingers and hand worked
their way around to my breast where they
stayed out of shot I remember him
breathing rather heavily and standing
there and thinking this is unbelievable
a co-presenter at the station saw the
incident even though I'd heard things I
didn't expect it to happen right in
front of me I wanted to knock his head
off I wanted to physically attack him
because of what he'd just done to my
colleague and friend yeah I was angry
and Jane Jane basically stopped me she
said please no don't don't don't
I said what do you mean don't and she
shouldn't look to Rolf Harris this is a
woman ward Paul Redmond worked on a
number of shows Harris appeared on went
back in Australia he'd tell female
colleagues to steer clear of the man
they nicknamed the octopus I used to
warn girls just look be careful don't go
for the cuddle at the end because he has
been known to grope
not me and them believe me and
unfortunately to their detriment that's
why I know six girls who have been
touched or off it was known as a family
entertainer but Rolf Harris will be
remembered as a man who exploited his
fame to indecently assaulting women on
both sides of the world
Jonathan Samuels Sky News Perth